yep PubMed is the government database of
all Scholastic biomedical literature so
36 million papers if you sit there long
enough and you have the passion you can
become a billionaire it's just a matter
of sitting there and sifting and sifting
and sifting which most people do don't
have the patient's desire or willpower
to do but every single biomedical
Innovation is is logged in on PubMed
[Music]
what's up we just had a conversation
with Martin shkreli if you don't know
who he is you can just Google his name
and you'll find that he is quote unquote
the most hated man in America or he is
the Pharma bro and he's uh you know he
touches kind of a bunch of different
things you know the bingo card for my
first million he's made hundreds of
millions of dollars he's super
controversial and some people love him
some people hate him he went to prison
for something that he did with his his
hedge fund and he comes on here and he
tells us a bunch of things he tells us
how he made his first million he gave
his side of the story on why he bought
that drug and raised the price and why
maybe it wasn't so evil as uh as it was
portrayed
um why he hates sort of vanilla CEOs
that that uh just only speak in
corporate speaking why he refuses to do
that uh why he thinks Mark Cuban is full
of [__] uh he also unveils his new
startup in the AI space for the first
time ever so uh pretty interesting
conversation with Martin he is uh he's
one thing he's not boring you'll look I
think we can all agree on that uh some
people love him some people hate him I
think you see in this episode you can
see a couple different sides of them and
so I'm curious to hear what you guys
think I would love for you to put in the
comments whether you uh you love this
episode you hated this episode or
somewhere in between and uh you know we
always commit that on this pod you know
when we bring people on we're not saying
this is the best person ever or the
worst we just want to have interesting
conversations with interesting people I
want to get into their mind and find out
why they are the way they are uh how
they think how they operate and then you
can decide for yourself whether this is
somebody you uh you're into or not so uh
that's this episode Martin shkreli it's
about two hour interview and uh enjoy
Sam where do you want to start we could
either go more on the AI stuff or
there's there's some interesting stuff
in your your kind of start of your
career that I think is kind of fun like
you worked you worked with Jim Cramer is
that right when you were 16 years old
you worked for Kramer the guy who's
always yelling on on CNBC uh what was
that like what's Kramer like
Kramer's right you know uh hedge funds
were a different world back then it was
a very very small asset class maybe 50
billion 100 billion totals
um you know any private partnership is
is technically kind of a hedge fund
right if you have outside investors and
you're charging them one and 20 or 2 and
20 and your shorting stocks and doing
exotic stuff you know that's a hedge
fund uh whether you call it that or not
so Warren Buffett had a hedge fund all
the folks had hedge fund but at the time
the biggest hedge funds were Galleon
group SAC Capital you know a handful
kind of like tiger Soros you know it was
sort of the wild time for the hedge fund
industry kind of you know very very
small industry maybe 30 or 40 or 50
firms of any significance uh and that
means like you know 100 million dollars
or more and so Kramer was one of those
firms I got to work there I was very
lucky
um you were in high school at the time
I was sort of in this like weird state
of both being a high school dropout a
high school graduate and a high school
you know continuing you know kind of
education it was very weird I had I went
to this very special school called
Hunter where I fulfilled all my degree
requirements pretty early so I was ready
sort of graduated in the state's eyes
but I continued to sort of like go to
the school and um pick up credits and
like go to college at the same time so
it was just a weird like mishmash of
education and um
sort of hard to explain but are you kind
of like you're almost like a Class Clown
of society now where you like that in
high school or were you just like a
straight laced kid at that time yeah
absolutely I was like just like this in
high school like it was if there was
somebody that needed sort of dressing
down or including yeah teacher or
principal whatever I remember my first
day of school I actually dressed down
the principal a bit that was sort of a
funny
you know thing to do you know I guess I
have to like fearlessness of you know
but did your parents like discipline you
were they like dude what the [__] show
some respect yeah
you know I I think not really [__] you
know I don't know you know I think
there's like this you know
I've always had this you know opinion
that people take themselves too
seriously and and take authority too
seriously and of course you know I
landed myself in prison but yeah I think
that you know there's uh and and you are
right they do take that accessories yeah
yeah another prediction one time uh
Martin was on blab and again the numbers
are going crazy I was like I got to see
what happened he must be acting a fool
or something I don't know what's going
on and uh
I go in and they're a CNN reporter was
demanding like an interview with him he
was like she was like you should Martin
uh I've been watching this it's really
interesting I would love to have a
conversation with you on CNN and he's
like no no you come on my show this is
my show you want to interview me we can
do it right here and she's like okay I'm
not gonna do that but if you come on CNN
he's like no no come on the show and
then she's like refusing or whatever
he's like she starts like trying to like
have a moment to like tell him how bad
he is and then he asked her he's like
I'm going to the gala tonight you want
to be my plus one
yeah didn't you end up going out didn't
you go out no not this one but uh I just
thought wow what a like you know they
don't teach that in PR school just ask
him on a date if it's not going if the
interview's not going well break
breaking down the fourth wall is like my
specialty right like you know I and what
Elon sort of did that to that BBC guy
the other day like I yep I would always
ask
um I remember one of my analysts uh
who's on the sell side before joining me
on the buy side they brought a
management team to come over to this
sort of skipping ahead in my career a
little bit to having my old phones uh he
brought a management team over to you
know pitch some stock or pitch a pipe or
something and I I asked the C CEO why he
didn't he didn't own any stock in his
company
and he you know he sort of like Hamming
and highing like you know that
temperature is kind of getting hot and I
said you know because I have your proxy
right here and I put a dumb table and I
said it looked like you make 550 000 a
year that's that's a good amount of
money can you promise me today that
you'll buy like 10 000 or 20 000 of your
stock at least and and the guy's just
sort of like you know the most
uncomfortable meeting in the history of
Wall Street you know because I kept like
hammering on I was like no but just tell
me like why can't you afford to spend
ten thousand dollars and buy your own
stock the stock price will go up
everyone wins you'll show confidence
that you know and I just wouldn't like
for 20 minutes let it go uh and it was
just you know one of these like you know
breaking down that fourth wall you're
not like you're not supposed to do that
you know his personal finances are up to
him is what most portfolio managers
would say you know he's allowed to not
own his stock it's it's really his call
but you know being able to sort of like
you know cut to the chase on half these
things and like you know address the
elephant in the room is kind of the
thing thing that I like to do even if
it's really uncomfortable or difficult
or embarrassing or you know a full paw
you know it's it's something that you
know I'll I'll just sort of you know cut
to the chase with well I remember when
you got arrested or the headline was
like uh you had to put up like your
Fidelity account or something like that
that had like 60 million dollars in it
and at the time you were I don't know
how old you were 32 or something I mean
early 30s very young and you I mean that
was it was a significant amount of money
and that didn't that was just your
Fidelity account let alone like your uh
you know the touring five uh you know
the the farm the Pharma companies that
you had founded was did you make your
first bit of money when you started the
hedge funds and how did that come to be
or were you already doing well just
being at the hedge funds where you
worked oh it's a great question so I
never made money I hedge funds I never
really made a dollar
um working at or owning both so when I
started at hedge funds I was young and
you know didn't really earn money uh
which was fine you know I wasn't
optimizing for that you know I was
optimizing for learning stuff experience
uh good relationships uh I mostly
succeeded in that I think you know
probably messed up some relationships
but regardless you know I did the best I
could as a young guy started my own fund
um pretty pretty terrible at doing the
fund management business you know
investing being a good investor and
being a good fund manager kind of like
pretty different things is what I think
most hedge fund entrepreneurs kind of
learn you know um you know there you can
be a really brilliant investor and not
manage the actual business well and the
business is to grow your assets as much
as possible provide the best sort of
adjusted returns possible and satisfy
your clients and I didn't really want to
do any of that you know I just wanted to
invest and
um I never took these from any of my
funds which was very like you know sort
of bizarre uh and they're they're sort
of technical legal reasons for that but
so I never really made any money uh in
hedge funds when I started my first drug
company called retropin which is now
called travier this is about 10 years
ago uh that's sort of where everything
sort of came together for me I I learned
Pharma by being a hedge fund person for
10 years and hedge funds studying Pharma
starting with the early Jim Cramer days
where I was just figuring out what a
stock in a bond was and then moving on
to you know trading these things and
working at hetrons and stuff like that
and then starting my own I I really
mastered Pharmaceuticals I I knew
everything about Therma and I impressed
a lot of people in Pharma who are
working in the field or working hedge
funds and you know it was easy for me to
sort of start a drug company and find
some really good assets
the first asset I found actually
received FDA approval just a couple
months ago so I'm really proud of that
and um when our company went public uh
you know as a millionaire how how old
were you it was 2012
um you know so I was born in 83 so I
guess it was 29 and um
I was a CEO publicly traded company and
um
the market Capital company like I said
now is you know 1.5 billion roughly and
uh the drug got FDA approved so I'm
really happy about that like so often in
biotech people start companies they kind
of extract some Equity value out of them
as they go public and then the company's
drugs don't work and
they kind of move on and there are
people that have like coasted and
biotech doing that like every three five
years you know I I name some names but
it doesn't matter you know and getting a
drug FDA approved and for me kind of on
my first try was you know sort of like a
very you know it's a very like nice
feather in my cap and I'm happy for the
people that are now getting this
prescription for this kidney disease I'm
really delighted by that but the you
know the it was a lot of fun to to see
that so when people ask me like where'd
you make your first million I made my
first like 25 million old one you're
still on the same day you know like it
wasn't like okay you make like one of my
great friends started off making
um you know he's a great story and one
day maybe you'll have them on this
podcast uh he started off trading uh
sneakers and um he was like 13 or
something and then he started trading
cars and he ended up trading stocks and
he he sort of went from a thousand bucks
to five thousand to a hundred thousand
to a million to five million you know et
cetera Etc and you know that that road
isn't when everyone does right like some
people I was like literally almost like
starving you know and like broke you
know trying to get that big big win and
it came through and so you you said a
couple things I want to uh quickly
clarify you see you didn't make much
money in investing because you weren't
really good at or interested in the fund
management but presumably if you're good
at or interested in the investing side
you would still generate return so what
was it like didn't didn't do so hot in
the on the investing side either or what
happened there
yeah I had a sort of like a mix of of
issues like when you run a small fund
you have like costs and stuff like that
so you know you have started how big how
big was the fun I had about eight
million
um you know ever since I started so like
you know you just can't like even with
good investing you just kind of can't do
that well with respect to to returns if
you have other costs and things like
that and you know we had like all kinds
of like
issues happen along the way that led to
that prosecution and stuff like that
that sort of limited our ability to do
really well financially
um and again we we didn't take any fees
either because again we had this sort of
big issue that that came about and we
just decided to not take fees at all but
in the end our investors did fairly well
um you know the record shows that our
investors all made money in our funds so
I was really happy to deliver that but
you know along the way there are a lot
of twists and turns and hiccups that are
not worth going into but hedge funds for
me were kind of like a just sort of like
a roller coaster of of
issues that were just over you know and
over again kind of like various like you
know unexpected twists and turns that
didn't really add up to profit some
people had hedge funds like if you get
off to like a good start
for your first like three or six months
often you can get this momentum raising
more capital and raising more capital
and you get this like virtuous cycle but
you can also go in the other direction
where you know if you you know many
funds are started by good investors and
they end up failing and those investors
sort of come back and take take a few
years off and start a fund again
um you know hedge funds have like the
shortest lifespan even though if you
look at the top hedge funds from the 90s
almost none of them exist today uh and I
think of those like top 10 hedge funds
of all time like five were shut down by
regulatory intervention so like it's a
very hazardous job you know there's
there's a you know 10 chance of going
going to jail being ahead for manager
it's it's uh it's a really you know kind
of dangerous job to be in and uh you
know you're dealing with the markets and
you're dealing with representations to
investors just how to Mark privates
right is kind of like one of these like
real debates I know a guy who went to
jail for that uh fairly recently
um you know anybody looking into your
books can basically say oh well you
marked this too high you know therefore
you you know you're you're defrauding
your investors for charging them too
much well you marked it too low well now
you're defroning them because you know
your your preferencing the other
investors who are coming into the fund
so you really can't can't win it's a
very tough business you don't build any
actual lasting value as you know almost
no hedge funds have gone public so it's
just kind of a crummy business in
general and like I I don't recommend
anyone kind of get into it unless
they're so interested in stocks that
they can't you know help but like spend
their whole time looking at stocks like
Kramer back then Kramer's like a stock
addict right so this guy again I
consider him you know not quite a friend
but like I I I have a fond memory of
working with a
I mean
he is like a a drug addict to their drug
he is like that to Securities like he
cannot get away from it there's nothing
he loves more in the world than stocks
and you think about people like Warren
Buffett and say maybe that's that's kind
of like them and the average person who
wants to get into hedge funds they
wanted to get into it because oh I can
make 10 million bucks or I can make 50
million bucks in a year wow look at that
Jim Simon made a billion dollars I can
be like that that sounds great and you
know that's a terrible terrible terrible
way to look at her right if you wake up
in the middle of night thinking about s
p earnings estimates you should be at
hedge funds right but if you don't care
on a Sunday you know what's what the
news is going to be on Monday in the
stock market or what you know your
favorite Company CEO is doing that night
you know that's it's not for you and I
think there are people that the hedge
fund industry has grown so much people
come to finance not understanding that
in the 90s and the 80s the only people
that were in hedge funds were people
like Jim and Buffett and people like
like that that were just like so
intensely insanely possessed by the
gyrations of the market and if that's
not you it's it's kind of not a good
industry but for me I I was sort of
intensely possessed with pharmaceutical
companies and pharmaceutical assets or
drugs and medicines and you know it was
actually a better fit to do private
Equity
um you know kind of style investing
where you actually buy whole medicines
whole companies you know that that
worked really well for me and I've seen
a lot of people in hedge funds sort of
transition to that model of well if I
can buy five percent of a software
company why can't I buy 100 of a
software company right that that makes
more sense to me and for me you lose
that like one of the things I was very
bad at at trading and investing was kind
of that impulse right where you have to
have this insanely good discipline as a
Trader and my partner had this really
really great discipline I didn't so I
could value security as good as anyone
but what it came time to like executing
and actually deploying capital and risk
management and stuff like that it was it
was much harder for me to be good at
that
um so when it came what is that what
what does that mean you're not patient
you you wanted the dopamine you wanted
the dopamine every one of those things
you're just you're just you're just like
a you have normal anxiety like a lot of
people is is that what that means I
think that like to ask somebody to
manage a portfolio well is one of the
most impossible tasks in like human
psychology because the and there's this
great book I've gotten better at it over
the years foreign
profit as my you know I basically
couldn't do that in in private investing
uh the
the hardest thing to do is is really to
fight two or three different for me
specific demons that are psychologically
based but everyone has their own demon
for me it's avoiding this this desire to
double down so the market is like this
really
tough psychological uh battle where
you're constantly going to be humbled
that your opinion is wrong that your
thesis is wrong but this stock is not
cheap you're wrong it's not cheap at all
and you got to sell it and that's really
hard cognitively to embrace
every day uh you could embrace it every
now and then oh yeah obviously I I
bought this crap stock and I'm wrong uh
but when you're right you do get that
dopamine hit and you don't want to
confront that loss of the dopamine hit
or even worse the acknowledgment that
you were wrong and you're gonna be wrong
like 40 50 of the time at best you know
say 35 40 of the time and most people
don't want to run ever so the desire is
sometimes to double down and just say no
I know I'm right this is an even better
opportunity than it was before if you
keep doing that you you basically will
will go bankrupt
um and uh it's like the fastest way to
go bankrupt and you know I've learned
that trick you know a couple times now
and and I think that you know I've
gotten better at sort of not doubling
down but it to be really great Trader
you got to not just not double down you
also have to get out you know before all
the damage is done and so I started to
do that well too but you know these
these pains are not pains your investors
want you to learn on their buying right
their uh their pains you have to sort of
you know be ready you know when you
start your own fun so I started starting
my fun too early and stuff like that but
I think that I wouldn't I wouldn't
change a lot in the sense that when you
have a fund you learn more about your
industry if you do it right I think you
learn more about your industry than than
any other sort of job other than
actually being in that industry so you
you learn a ton about what Wall Street
wants so let's say if you're a software
analyst it's really great to then have a
software company because you know
exactly kind of what the exit looks like
and what like public company investors
want to see and the same thing works in
biotech and biotech to handicap like oh
this company or stock be a good stock
well you got to figure out will this
drug be good drug and that's the exact
same skill set you have to do when your
CEO so you have that like you know um
crossover that's happening quite a bit
more in biotech I've seen that you know
it doesn't happen so much in tech people
who invest in Tech generally don't want
to be operators and the tricks that you
have to learn on the operating side in
Tech are very different from biotech and
biotech you can actually like learn
pickle mostly operating stuff from being
an investor uh whereas I think in Tech
like you know being an investor and
software company certainly doesn't make
you a programmer you know so you know
and that that's what I was going to ask
you because you you were like well I
started a pharmaceutical company because
I loved the asset and I learned through
it for finance which is way different
than like for example my friend Cara
started this company hint which does
like water because she was like my skin
was bad I didn't want to drink Gatorade
or Coke anymore so I like went and
formed I went and boiled fruit Peels and
made this fruit water that's like tastes
good it's good for you and we grew from
there your founding story was like oh I
found assets that were interesting like
it's like that's like foreign to me you
know what I mean yeah so like if if
there was a company for example uh my
first hedge fund we bought 10 of this
company publicly traded company and they
had bought this asset from Bristol Myers
the major major drug company in New
Jersey and Bristol Meyer spent like 50
million bucks developing this drug and
they quit they basically said this
doesn't fit our portfolio we're not
really going after the disease they were
trying to go after was hypertension
which is very boring and that does not
need another medicine there's like 60
hypertension drugs you know it does not
need to be a 61st and they they just
quit on the drug
um there are people who have like really
bad resistant hypertension and so forth
so I really like this asset I like the
way it worked and I after Bristol Myers
quit on it the publicly traded company
and the financial crisis they merged
with another public trade company so I
went to the publicly trade company and
again only thing I have is a hedgehog
moment and I said let me buy and
nobody's told a story by the way so this
is a good time to tell it because it's
really you know it's basically a story
about how we went to this company with
two million dollars and turned it into
over Rebellion
um you know which is is kind of
remarkable but people do this in Pharma
every day and my friend uh and at the
time it was actually my biggest investor
vivekan Swami is now running for
president he basically took our business
model and supersized it and again um you
know who who influence two is is a
matter well left really left to history
but the the point is we went to uh this
company that had the license from
Bristol and they had they were doing
anything with it and we said let's
listen we'll take this we'll find
investors we'll build a company around
it and uh I'm gonna figure out how to
how to make this work and they said okay
sure you know we we got this asset
sitting here doing nothing if you pay us
two million bucks we'll we'll send you
the 2 million bucks now we sent them a
million dollars which was really
catastrophic because you never want to
sort of go back in your word uh but it
was really like a dire circumstance
where I forgot what happened exactly but
we just couldn't come up with money and
it was like we sent them a million and
they're like what the [__] you know you
can't do this this you know and I I was
sort of like you know geez this is a you
know huge embarrassment a huge problem
but she's gonna have to give us like 30
days or 90 days and you know we we
worked it out and we were able to give
him the second million but it was like
this colossal embarrassment right at the
start and um you know [__] does happen
but you know it ideally shouldn't happen
like that um and again really
embarrassing and tough but we got
through the 2 million and we decided I I
sort of did all this research and said
instead of hypertension we should go
with this rare kidney disease called
focal segmental glomerulosclerosis and
if you just don't PubMed and you have
the willpower you can learn a lot about
medicine and you can dive in and PubMed
PubMed just being like a database of
Articles yeah I guess yep PubMed is the
government database of all Scholastic
biomedical literature so 36 million
papers if you sit there long enough and
you have the passion you can become a
billionaire it's just a matter of
sitting there and sifting and sifting
and sifting which most people do don't
have the patient's desire or willpower
to do but every single biomedical
Innovation is is logged
you were sifting for what what were you
looking for when you went on PubMed yeah
you have to put the pieces together so
the the this drug was an endothelial and
receptor antagonist uh and what does
that mean it it inhibits a protein
called endothelium and its function well
what will that do right you have to
decide well you have to learn where is
endothel and it expressed in the body
how does it work what does it do if I
stop and to see one from working what
benefits will that have What problems
will that result in and if you look at
the history of okay well other companies
have tried this what have they seen what
have they discovered and what's
interesting about Pharma is that you
think that these companies Cover the
Waterfront but they really just prod and
poke a little bit there's actually
probably 10 diseases that this drug
could be beneficial for and uh I made a
list of those and I said okay well which
one of these is gonna work for sure and
they're companies that like got half the
answer and stuff like that and you just
have to keep poking and we found like
these handful of diseases that really
made a lot of sense now the problem was
nobody in Wall Street really liked it
um you know it was very
you know kind of early you know there
was this sort of tough problem of
if you reduce the amount of protein in
the urine of a patient does that really
save their kidney and I thought I
convinced everyone that I could reduce
the amount of protein in the urine which
was a very big end point to me but not
as conclusive as okay am I saving their
lives am I am I preventing dialysis and
kidney failure which is really the
so-called hard end point so I had the
soft end point that like seemed like
almost certain I was right and I was
starting to convince companies like Abby
and vertex and other like big bio
Farmers that you know I was onto
something that nobody wants to write a
check you know so I basically got one of
the management teams that I I used to
deal with on on Wall Street uh 10 best
and I slowly kind of cobbled together
some money uh met folks like Peter Thiel
and others to to try to sort of get some
investors
did a reverse merger what's Peter Thiel
like meters great you know it was you
know 10 10 plus years ago he had never
done Pharma
um so we we got to meet and this was
going to be basically like his first
Pharma deal ever uh we didn't end up
doing the deal but it was uh it was a
very funny thing because like there was
this East Coast versus West Coast
mentality uh you know as a Wall Street
guy he was you know he's obviously you
know one of the top VC type guys and
this is a time where like he had clarium
you know their Founders one was just
getting started and stuff like that and
uh you know the Wheeling dealing like
Wall Street sort of style of like oh
we're gonna do a reverse merger which is
basically kind of like a spack with no
money
um you know it's like even worse than
SPAC
um you know you do the you do the
listing and then you raise the money uh
but it's a way to go public and we did
it and he was like ah you can't go
public in a year or two and you know the
reality is you kind of can in especially
biopharma where the assets are like
these very modular systems they're not
like a base business that has X dollars
revenue and it's growing at X rate these
are like okay this asset's worth
something dead or alive in other words
if it's being developed or not being
developed it towards something uh you
know especially with the right business
plan uh it could be worth a lot so
anyway we we decided go publicly raise
the money we started doing clinical
trials the trial worked uh and the rest
is history but it took you know it takes
hundreds of millions dollars to develop
a drug uh again the value of the company
is is 1.5 the value of that drug
specifically is probably around 1
billion uh again whether it actually
achieves the sales goals or beats them
or disappoints we'll see as the drug
launches and I'm rooting for the company
uh but uh so you you didn't even you
didn't even get the drug in this example
you didn't get the drug to the point
where people were buying it or using it
it was you made money off just the the
fact that this will exist hopefully in
10 or whatever years yeah this is where
well a lot of people don't know my story
about medicine a lot of people think
that I take medicines and raise prices
well this drug was barely inhuman beings
it had been in like 30 or 50 people
um up until that point and you know I
made most of my money uh in in sort of
developments in in environment on the
research side so you know this is a drug
in clinical research so no it's not it
hadn't been FDA approved it would take
10 years to get it SDA approved so it
was a long marathon of running studies
getting the evidence running more
studies getting more evidence and
continuing that process and you know uh
as we started to do that the value of
the company increased and people said
okay I think I get this and then as the
data came in now it's FDA approved it's
called philspari I named the drug
sparcentan
um you know gave it his first chemical
name and um you know it's it's you know
I'm so happy it's it's FDA approved now
I left the company halfway through this
process so I should acknowledge that but
you know all the same plans and and so
forth you know continued did you did you
own most of it at the time or what was
that and did you have to divest when all
the [__] went down
so I went from 90 you know when we
started it to 50 uh when we're public I
think I had around 40 or 50 after our
first financing down to 30 under second
financing down to 20. you know set time
of our IPO we when you do reverse word
very often don't get on on NASDAQ so we
did an IPO on NASDAQ 2014 and the
company was worth like three or four
hundred million and I owned about 15 20
of it and uh again this is sort of like
my first wealth ever but the funny thing
is
as you guys maybe know you have a
situation like that you actually don't
have any cash you're not liquid yeah you
can't sell it so you know I've got
millions of shares of the stock but you
know I'm sitting there saying okay well
you're like how am I gonna buy this
album yeah exactly well you know the
level for that you think about like how
am I gonna buy this five thousand dollar
a month apartment and go to the seven
thousand dollar a month apartment which
is like a very funny discussion for
somebody that you know has 50 or 100
million dollars uh of of stock value and
I would go to these Banks and say listen
can I borrow five percent you know of my
money of my stock value and they would
say no and you know I'd say you know uh
you know why not you know they'd say
well here's a new stock you know it's
it's kind of you know still you know a
little bit unseasoned you're the big
shareholder you know we're just not
comfortable with it and it's like
sitting there like oh my God you know
this is insane because I don't want to
sell my stock because it sounds like
kind of a bad signal to the market
um you know but I don't want to you know
uh also starving so it was a very like
funny thing and I don't want to be one
of those greedy CEOs that has you know
an insane salary uh where you don't need
it so it's very just sort of a funny
circumstance but eventually uh we had a
big squabble at the company uh I ended
up leaving uh it's very tumultuous and
and
uh traumatic story in a lot of ways and
it led to my prosecution uh you know
there was this fight with with the board
and it got very so nasty that the the
board you know kind of evil people here
but the board sort of went to law
enforcement uh as kind of one of their
ways to win this fight and you know one
of the things that a lot of people don't
understand is that there's this big
revolving door between corporate law and
law enforcement when I said law
enforcement I mean the Attorney General
sorry ausa is the associate U.S
attorneys that work in the Department of
Justice
and it's not hard if you go to a law
firm you know like a [__] Cleary got
leaves God and Arabs picture Paul wise
pick your biggest Law Firm you say hey
we have this guy he did something bad
you know look into this you know usually
you'll get into Diamond pretty fast this
happened at the Google guy that uh had
the uh waymo yeah Andrew uh this
happened to a Goldman Sachs Trader that
stole some source code the email emailed
himself home to work on the source code
then he went to another hedge fund they
said see he stole an electorate the FBI
got him in 48 hours Goldman makes a
phone call uh they'll act on it quickly
Google makes a phone call they'll act on
it quickly you're a big enough Law Firm
customer you're paying a law firm 10
million bucks and all those Law Firm
Partners worked in government right they
worked literally in the job they can get
United so they could pick up a phone and
get it and make it happen and I actually
have like the person's name who picked
up the phone you know and it's it's like
so ridiculous because a boardroom battle
a corporate squabble shouldn't turn into
you know okay let me just make call and
get you know get this guy arrested then
we'll win the fight right and it's like
you know I was actually acquitted of
those charges and I'm so proud of that
um to this day it's like the most the
happiest thing that I have to look
forward to or to talk about because like
it was this Clash of like these old hand
old older incompetent sort of bio people
and this these younger sort of like
aggressive Executives said that I
Shopper did and the older guys kind of
won in terms of control of the company
but the stock never went up again really
and you know it it just was sort of this
company that they were able to sort of
cite in millions of dollars out out of
uh which is like for for a lot of
talentless Executives like that's that's
really exciting like getting a a five
million dollar paycheck a year plus a
you know golden parachute plus all the
perks and the power of being the CEO
like I've none of that stuff mattered to
me I just wanted to make really big
money and really big advances and for a
lot of people like you know getting that
the thing I just discussed was like
that's their wife call that's their
career goal there's no no need to do
anything else they they'd rather preside
over a company that does nothing
what pays them five million bucks a year
then a company that makes a huge advance
in a treatment or whatever so it was
this big fight and and I just basically
said I'll start a new company I don't
need you guys and I started uh touring
we should uh let you explain kind of the
thing because if people listen to this
have basically only heard of you as the
guy who jacked up the price of the drugs
and I've heard you explain this before
many times where again uh I said you
were entertaining because somebody would
come on and be like you're the worst
you're like you're evil you did this and
then you would say
so explain to me what I did exactly and
then they would immediately not know
what the hell to say like you you raised
the price of the drug and now people
can't get it you're like tell me who
can't get it where are you getting that
data from like what what and you would
walk them through almost like the
Socratic method of um what actually
happened why what your perspective was
on it and so I want you to share that
because I think a lot of people have
heard the other perspective which is guy
buys drug raises price he's evil that's
one perspective I'd like you to share
your perspective and then people could
decide for themselves which they feel to
be more true so and you didn't even and
and it was another funny part related to
that is you didn't even go to prison for
that reason right you if I remember
correctly you admitted you were wrong
for a bunch of things uh but it wasn't
even related your persona was your your
yeah yeah but you're I think you being
smug and being an [__] when maybe you
should have just been like yes ma'am I'm
sorry was maybe probably the more
appropriate answer but you were kind of
like being smug and you got a lot of
[__] for that so I think that hurt your
your thing but you didn't even get
processed you didn't get prosecuted for
that no yeah it's not a it's I mean I
think that's why I was so small because
it's not a crime to choose the price of
your product you know if you guys wanted
to charge for for this podcast right you
you know whether it's an Advertiser or a
partner or or The Listener maybe you
could pick whatever price you want you
know that's your call you know it's your
job to explore the frontier of that
price and volume curve and it your job
to sort of find the maximum Revenue uh
you can choose to do that or not do that
and I think that's why American
capitalism is so great it's like it's
it's really the only person's call is
the firm owner and the firm management
teams call right it's not a politician's
call it's not the media's call it's not
the guy in the you know in this sort of
uh grandstands call you know you know
hooting and hollering at you it's it's
not even the patient's call even though
they're your core constituent and we
care the most about them it's it's your
call as management team right you said
that price when you email the
distributor that's the price that
matters it's the price that you picked
and nobody can tell you what for that
price is and any business and what was
that what was that logic that you that
Sean was referring the criticism would
be you yes yes you had the right to
raise the price that doesn't mean you're
not a jerk or that people weren't hurt
by that because they now couldn't afford
it so now address that part of it the
reverse psychology is a super important
I'll go through that in a second but I
think the most of you know what you said
is really important because it's this
like inviolable right and I I was really
pissed off quite frankly that there was
this effort by by Paul wannabe would be
politicians that didn't end up winning
uh and and others to try to sort of take
that right away
uh through like this regulation by
embarrassment right like it was like
this like well shame you until you
change your mind it's like oh you're
gonna shame me into changing my mind
like you know that that's insane you're
trying to take my right away it's my
right to run my business how I see fit
now we'll go through all the logic of
why I think it was a good idea an
attenable idea and it's not something a
jerk would do it's not something an
[__] would do but just first and
foremost you know how dare you try to
tell me you know what my price should be
because ultimately every person in
America is working for some business
that sets their price and you're
basically saying well if you do it to me
what you can do to Apple next or you can
tell them that the iPhone's too
expensive you're gonna do it to your
podcast where an Advertiser says oh my
God you want fifty thousand dollars to
post a an ad on my podcast well that's
not right I want that for 25 000. you
know you're not getting the ad and you
know I think that there's this special
difference when it comes to healthcare
and I've learned this and processed it
slowly and like I said I'll tell you
briefly about my new company in a minute
but people treat Healthcare products and
services in a different part of their
mind you know a friend of mine worked at
Amex and got to talk to Buffett about
this where he said Buffett likes
businesses where consumers think about
the brand with a different part of their
mind they don't think about it with
rational part they think about it with
the emotional part and Amex is an
emotional product Coca-Cola is an
emotional product you don't think about
and say well this soda water costs you
know sugar water costs 20 cents to make
I don't know if I want to buy this for a
dollar you know you just buy the soda
because you watch Coca-Cola and and the
more that you can make people think with
that side of their their brain the
better in healthcare you kind of get
this like very visceral like entitlement
of like no I meet this drug I don't care
what it costs for the producer I don't
care any like this is my right to get
this medicine and obviously you know
that they're that's not quite right in
my opinion so getting back to to sort of
just again getting past my just
annoyance that there'd be people that
sort of felt like you know they had a
right to tell you what your prices
should be without knowing anything about
your business in the first place uh I
think the biggest thing that worked on
with that Socratic method is just
showing people how little they know
about they're in this industry right
most people don't know much about the
farm industry I don't blame them for
that right this is the industry I spent
my life in uh to know that it's an ins
and out of Pharma you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't be I'd be surprised if anybody
did so the first thing I tend to ask is
well what price do you think product
should be and this is sort of where like
it all falls apart for for the
interlocutor because the average
pharmaceutical price would shock most
people you know there are rare disease
drugs uh like spinraza and the avexis
product for SMA they're millions of
dollars you know it's a million dollars
for a drug a year you know so every year
for the rest of your life you got to pay
a million bucks you know there are drugs
like that but I think that's probably
out of pocket right it's nobody's paying
out of pocket for energy
you know to the insurance company not to
the end patient correct you know we have
this convoluted crazy system that
generally needs to kind of be broken in
half uh but you know and again I'll show
you my product in a minute that unlike
Mark Cuban's garbage is might actually
help uh the uh the um you know the the
first question I always ask people is
like well what do you where do you price
a drug what do you have I've been I had
a drug at retrofin 60 people okay six
zero and they needed it to save their
life what what price should that be
should it be the price of Viagra no yeah
yeah I believe in this thing called
utility theory of price which I probably
studied in in economics a long time ago
but forgot but this this this idea is
that price has three or four different
theories of of price there's theory of
kind of value there's theory of utility
and there's sort of other types of
theories like it should cost a lot of
people sort of like would give me their
theories in in Lay terms like well it
should cost what you made it plus a
comfortable margin I was okay that
sounds interesting and other people say
well it should cost what is worth to the
user and and that's kind of how most
medicine is priced if you can forego
some terrible operation
you know then and that operation is
really expensive by taking this medicine
it should sort of cost the price of you
foregoing that operation and it's like
but for analysis right so for a lot of
rare diseases it's like well but for
this drug you would be spending hundreds
of thousand dollars a year so it's kind
of a bargain at say a hundred thousand
dollars because otherwise the insurance
is going to spend half a million on you
you know going to the hospital every
week and so forth and so forth if you
price someone based on what it would
cost like okay well prices are going to
break even well not a lot of incentive
to make a medicine like that right you
want to kind of want this windfall
profit if you're a drug company because
you have this risk that this shit's not
gonna work and then you know you'll
you'll be a you'll be on uh applying to
a job advisor you know after your
biotech startup fails so if you do win
you can't just break even you know you
have to overcome the risks and the risk
adjusted possibility that you would have
failed otherwise nobody would invest in
companies like this if all the benefit
was you would break even so you have to
have this extra return and so when you
do the pricing I think that the best
logical thing to do is pick a price that
the Alternative Care in other words a
world without this drug you would forego
all those costs for this drug and so I
think that price works there are people
who are you know just literally
legitimately out of their mind that say
oh the drug should be just should just
be free and of course you know we're
who's going to pay for the office who's
going to pay for lawyers who's gonna pay
the accountant who's gonna pay first
who's gonna pay for the next drug right
if every drug is free then nobody's
going to want to go make drugs and again
I if the if that's the system Society
dictated to me I I you know I'll follow
those rules but the society the the
system Society dictated was it's your
choice let's price your product at it's
the insurer's choice to pay for it it's
the Doctor's choice to prescribe it and
there are countries like there's this
miracle drug by vertex one of my
favorite drug companies for Cystic
Fibrosis Miracle product literally cure
for Cystic Fibrosis amazing cystic is no
longer a medical problem for 90 of
people with cystic fibrosis this company
should have parades
parades every year for it right but
instead they get [__] for it and I have
friends that if their lives have been
saved one of my friends in high school
died of cystic fibrosis at 19. and these
guys are doing I use this term very
carefully God's work by by saving people
CF there are countries that refuse to
pay for the medicine right this is 300
000 a year and my drug I ask people all
the time well how much is my drug well I
say that I know you had 750 pills that's
not what I'm asking in Pharma we don't
worry about what the price put bullets
we worry about what does it cost for
somebody to have to pay for this
medicine out of pocket what is the
insurance paying for a full course or a
full year
right and they said well I don't know
how many pills do you do you have to
take when you take this drug that you
raise the price up and I said well why
are you ready to criticize me when you
don't know what the total cost is you
know you're you're already jumping up
but you know why they're criticizing you
which is like as I'm listening this this
you talk like you have this very classic
uh issue which is both uh uh it's uh an
asset and a liability which is you're
quite uh logical so you're like this one
guy I forget the guy's name the the guy
who's running for president he just did
what I did and he did it times 10 but I
did it early on which is like you filed
a very logical thing which is we hear
this all the time and we have friends
like this where it's like
well I thought it could work because of
X Y and Z and in most people's heads
they would say to themselves yeah but no
one else is doing it therefore it's
impossible in your head which is a very
common thing and entrepreneurs like you
which is no like if a then B then C like
the very logical approach but where you
have [__] up is you weren't it's like
it's like you're so smart at studying
the logic that you also kind of [__]
up by studying like okay but if I do
that then people will hate me therefore
I should probably use these words or
smile this way when they confront me and
like that was like a it's kind of like
what elon's doing it's like dude you're
so [__] smart Elon you're doing all
this amazing [__] don't call Twitter
titter like think of a different troll
that's a like that's a net positive not
a negative and that was what it seemed
like was your thing which is like yeah
dude you're logical you're not wrong
about this this and this but you're just
being a [__] idiot when you're
talking about it and you're not like
like what don't smile that way you know
even if you're I respect it because I'm
like I think you know and I'm sure you
were told by people what the correct way
to frame and spend this is and yeah
so so I I can I can be just like the guy
at Pfizer right just like right and I
can and I and I think it's cool that
you're not that guy but it's like well
that's the issue you could you could
have saved seven years of your life
maybe and Only God
just like be a little bit more likable
sometimes to save your own ass and sure
and and you know I I wanted to straddle
that line but like how much or like when
I when I talk at Ivy League schools I
get standing ovations because I think
that the kids realize that they're the
life their personality is about to be
choked out by the the big Pharma big
corporate world right where they're
going to the Pharma are they going to to
finance their life is is older you know
their ability to express themselves the
way they see fit is done right their
their ability to wear what they want to
work is over and I think that I
represent that fresh event fresher
that's like okay maybe they actually
keep a personality maybe you can
actually be somebody real instead of you
know look look at this average CEO of
corporate America lift up Budweiser CEO
anhurst CEO it's like no I I gotta say
what is the maximally the least
interesting and the least offensive
possible road to walk and they can't
have a real personality because if I do
you know someone's gonna have an issue
with it and it's going to be a problem
for my business and I just hate the that
the corporate world has gotten to that
point where you know showing who you are
or the kind of person you are or having
an opinion of any kind can be held
against you I agree and the world wants
you to be vanilla I'm on look this is
why people like our pod I also see the
other side where it's like yeah dude but
you just [__] up all those like I
don't know if this is true but maybe it
is you just messed up all the people who
wanted this drug because you got locked
up and or you hurt your family or you
hurt people who cared about you all
because of you wanting to express
yourself if you want to express yourself
get a [__] dog go hang out with your
cat like talk to them like you know what
I mean that's that's
is really important
how many people could not afford or did
not were not able to access the drug
that previously could when the price was
lower because the price got raised was
it
um one percent ten percent fifty percent
seventy five percent of people could no
longer afford the drug because that's
the clear right zero zero percent so so
that's the thing that like you know not
how far it works so explain that part
because I think that's the key
consideration uh is if you raise the
price of the drug and these people who
needed it to pay for their their illness
could no longer afford it and now they
were sort of out you know [__] out of
luck because you bought the drug and and
decided to reprice it that would have
been one thing I think there's a I think
that would support the argument against
in a way at least the emotional argument
against but when you add the fact that
nobody lost access to the drug or very
small percentage if that's true I don't
know if it's true I don't do I don't do
the research on this but you're saying
that that's true that completely changes
the argument in my opinion I I think so
too and and that's why like I was so
bold and and to Sam's Point you know
seemingly like toned ass right about
this because I wanted people to see well
it's not a stupid person why is he being
so tone deaf and obstinate hopefully
it's because he's right and and let me
look into that and some people did you
know and that's why I've got fans uh and
I'm not Billy McFarland or somebody like
that I'll be able to raise money and
start a new business because you know I
accomplish things and I'm a skilled guy
uh it's it's this like failure to so
it's desire to want to buy a narrative
from Media or buy
anger or rent anger uh that that sort of
accumulated to your people when it comes
to Medicine like like I said there are
drugs far more expensive than there from
and uh like 500 000 or more per year
they're from the one-time one course
right so there's not an insurer in the
world that didn't cover their room
because
if you don't pay the fifty thousand
dollars roughly what they're from costs
for a whole course forget per pill about
50 Grand if you end up needing their
problem uh if you don't pay that you're
gonna pay for the guy's funeral you're
gonna pay for us actually you visits
you're paying for us you know you're
gonna pay for a million bucks of this
guy being the ICU for the next six
months it doesn't make sense right
financially to not pay for derogram the
other thing is it's such a small
medicine this was less than 0.1 percent
of an insurer's budget right it's
[__] not even not even a policy is
being formed at Aetna or United
Healthcare because it's like no they
have automation policies for this stuff
like until the drug ends up being like a
couple more basis points you know
several dozen basis points it's just not
going to be a factor right they're more
worried about is somebody taking insulin
when they could be taking metformin
which is much cheaper right make them
make 20 000 people move from insulin to
metform you know that or fifty thousand
or five hundred thousand people our
policy is you got to take OTC before you
get this that's prescription that's the
kind of policies Healthcare health
insurance care about again you wouldn't
know that unless you're in the
healthcare industry right and the
problem is when you have people that are
that are shooting at you you know and
they don't know what your industry is
about you know it's it's akin to me
telling like a database programmer well
you know nosql databases are better than
SQL databases and he's like why why are
you saying that well and he starts
putting out all these data I'm like oh
that's just that's just how I feel like
you know it's better to have a no sequel
than a sequel that's like I wouldn't do
that because I'm not that intellectually
dishonest but people are very willing to
be intellectually dishonest when it
comes to things they don't know about
because you know it's a personal thing
and again my my goal is to better
understand how personal Healthcare is to
people that it actually is this
cherished good and service it's not like
food it doesn't have the elasticity of
other things it's a very unique product
that we put in a different place and you
know my new company is as sort of an
effort to sort of understand that make
make amends make Penance in a way
because I think that again Healthcare is
one of these Goods that unlike most
other Goods there's a marginal the
marginal demand demand for marginal
Health Care is virtually infinite well
amongst the three of us nobody is
willing to sacrifice marginal health
care right you and I are probably
willing to sacrifice marginal you know
clothing right there's only so much
money I'm going to spend on clothing
there's only so much money I'm going to
spend on on this or that but if you had
infinite money like the thing you'd
probably prioritize is your health you
know your livelihood and well-being and
I think that that makes it kind of the
special that in service and that's why
we've spent we've gone from 75 of our
GDP on Health Care to 20 and I think
that's going to go to 50 over time
because our basic goods and needs are
mausoleilian kind of needs or Med you
know we can eat we can have shelter Etc
et cetera we ultimately just want to
live forever there's no this reason why
the Silicon Valley trillionaires they
want longevity right they want like the
they want to be around forever because
you know Larry Ellison you know I grew
up kind of you know a little bit
fanboying or worshiping you know his
life goal is to live forever and he's
not gonna make it but this this idea
that all these guys sort of have in
their minds that if they spend their
billions they'll live forever it's it's
there because they love their whites
right the average person Africa probably
doesn't think about it that way I think
they'd like to but their their Life's a
lot harder uh in America we're really
lucky we want to live forever because of
that and I think that makes Health you
know one of these things where it's
demand side driven you know we like to
think that Healthcare expenses are going
up because of people like me or people
like the Milan CEO or the vicer CEO
they're only because we all demand
Healthcare we want health for everyone
our families our friends our progeny we
all want Healthcare uh you know to to
we're going to consume more and more of
it over time
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better I I want to
ask you about your new thing and then I
want to ask about your predictions but
first when you got out of prison how
much of that nut did you still have left
and what do you do with your money now
what are you investing in now or are you
just doing like are are you even allowed
to trade and are you just doing like
boring index funds are you doing more
risky stuff what are you doing yeah so I
got into a very interesting litigation
so I was able to pay my court my
criminal fines very very relatively
easily it was around 8 million bucks
um in that process I I decided to sell
the Wu-Tang album uh which is a funny
thing because there's this nft bubble
and I basically saw like if I turn this
into an nft or sell to a crypto bro like
you know I'll I might even get my money
back on this thing because it was
basically just you know a lark and I
didn't think I'd uh
I I marked it as down like 75 but I was
able to actually turn a profit on it so
I was happy to time that bubble well
um so I was able to pay my criminal
fines off but then I got into this
litigation with the FTC uh the Federal
Trade Commission actually personally
sued me for Monopoly I'm the first
person in American history the Sherman
Act which is 125 years old the first
person to personally be sued by the
Federal Trade Commission which is very
odd because John D Rockefeller Bill
Gates Mark Zuckerberg a couple of people
who are accused of monopolies their
firms got sued I was actually the first
person to personally be sued as a
monopolist uh which is very odd uh and
they won so I'm appealing that but they
want a 60 million dollar hit against me
so until I figure that out I'm sort of
not not in the market
um it's very like bizarre ruling that I
think will get overturned but again it
shows you that kind of like animus like
this judge they made their ruling will
that make you bro if I had to pay the 60
I think I I could pay the 60 but it's
it's just like a colossal [__] you know
just a colossal like you know
it hit in the gears of like stopping
like the production basically so uh the
company I also wanted to indemnified so
the company will probably have to pay it
but it's just a big like [__] at
the moment so you know I'm I'm sort of
focused again the nice thing about being
an entrepreneur and having faith in your
talent and things like that is that even
if you wiped me out and start at zero I
wouldn't have a problem I think you know
getting making several hundred million
dollars I I think that any business I
start
you know it may not be this one or the
next one but eventually with
perseverance I'll have some great
success and I think that there's not you
know a bone in my body that doesn't
believe that and I think when you can
find great assets or great people and
put Capital together with that that you
know magic starts to happen and and it's
a infectious and contagious and you know
as long as you have your sort of Mooring
straight you should be able to do it and
I think that we we've already started
that process so whether this litigation
turns out that I'll have to pay you know
six some amount of that's been paid by
the company and if I don't have
indemnification something could be maybe
off to 8 30 or 40 million bucks and it
would suck sure you know I'd have to
sell my farm assets I'd have to you know
make room would I could be able to cover
it or not I'm not even 100 sure but you
know it all depends on the sale price uh
but you know even even if you sort of
took everything for me yet you know and
and added another 100 million I'd sort
of be you know you know cheery about it
and say all right it's a big challenge
but I'll do it you know and I think that
you know I don't I don't view sort of
wealth and and success as as symmetrical
or the the same thing I sort of say that
you know
um you know it's sort of almost like you
know a challenge to sort of like do it
the other way I know a lot of people
like they make money to be comfortable
like I almost feel like I make money to
be uncomfortable okay I want I want the
bigger challenges the harder things to
do like you look at Elon Musk and you
got you you gotta ask yourself like why
is this guy making his life so much
harder new businesses new ideas like
what is going on in his head that he
wants more pain because it's very
painful to deal with all the headaches
of these companies oh half your
advertisers just left at Twitter oh by
the way you still have to pay the
interest like I should be sitting there
like oh my God you know this is so much
pain like why add this on top of my
Tesla issues because you know there's
100 issues of that company you know it's
100 issues it's Basics and again
business is going great at those
companies but they're still intense
issues that you have to deal with every
day and you've got all their lawsuits
and you've got all those things going on
in your personal life you have eight
kids I mean why add more [__] to your to
your your thing and I think the answer
for me is like I love it you know I I
love the game and you know whether or
not you know my bank's accounts got this
many zeros without any zeros I you know
it's not like you're gonna be spending
it you know it's it's uh it's just work
you know I I sit in a room with my my
team and I work all day and that's it so
for me it's it's like I don't know if
you fall in the fall but he has this
great quote uh he has this like Twitter
thread called uh how to get rich without
getting lucky and he says something in
there that I love which he goes
um I don't want to just get rich I want
to be a person who gets Rich meaning uh
if you could drop if you took everything
away from me and you dropped me you know
sort of like butt naked in a third world
country in 10 years I want to be wealthy
again and I think I have this I have
built the skills in order to do that and
so that sort of reminds me of what
you're talking about which is like look
you might lose everything that you made
in the last decade or have have uh have
this sort of like reset but
it give you 10 years you'll build back
up and I think most great entrepreneurs
are are built that way and wired that
way and almost in a sick way kind of
relish that that opportunity when that
Misfortune strike there is some fortune
in that Misfortune uh when a situation
yeah it's sort of fun I mean in some
ways like I think a lot of people you
know like a comeback story too you uh
you talked about the like you know you
didn't want to be the Pfizer CEO you
didn't want you you kind of knew what
you needed you could have said and you
decided like f that like I don't wanna
I don't want to do business I'm putting
words in your mouth a little bit but
it's sort of like I don't want to be a
CEO that type of CEO and I don't want to
play the game of Entrepreneurship I
don't like the world when it's less
interesting when people don't actually
say what's on their mind or uh can speak
like a normal human being versus being
like this like very tightly wound you
know corporate you know uh uh duck and
so I don't know if you've seen this but
have you seen have you guys seen this
movement that happened at Stanford the
fun Strikes Back movement
so have you heard about this yeah no
absolutely it's awesome there's
basically so there was like the student
body election I guess and I don't know
the full story because I just read about
this I was reading about this this
morning I was supposed to be prepping
for this but the story fascinated me
instead and um
basically there was a group of people
that are at a group of students that
were running at Stanford and they won
the election on this movement that
they're calling Fun strikes back and
they're basically like dude you know
campus in the university has just
drained us of our personality it is
trying to shut down all the fun things
that they're like we are Pro Athletics
we're pro fraternities we are pro
partying and we are pro-weirdness and
they basically talk about like the the
story they do a great job telling the
story they're like you know back in 1981
um this you know there's this frat party
where that they threw every year where
there was sand all over the house uh
like a beach party or whatever and at
the end of the night like the the party
was over people left but the sand was
still there they're like [__] what are
we gonna do with all this sand we still
have so much insane they're like what if
we built an island with the sand and
they're like there's this little Lake
what if we took all the sand to the
middle of the lake we made an island and
that could be our Island and they like
rallied at four or five in the morning
and they go there and then the
groundskeepers like guys you can't bring
a bulldozer here like an excavator to
like dump this here and they're like sir
we want to do this for this reason this
is our moment this is our Legacy like
think about this years from now people
will wonder how the hell this Island was
built and tonight is that night and the
guy's like all right go ahead okay and
he like lets them in they pulled the
island and it's this epic party or
whatever it's the Epic finish
and then like fast forward to today like
uh the island got the island is gone the
lake is gone they shut everything down
nobody can visit that little Pond or
that lake anymore because there was like
an endangered salamander there so
they're like no no shut it down guys and
then like one by one they've kicked off
all the fraternities from from the from
the campus for like whatever violation
they hit a violation They removed them
from campus they like scraped all the
like each each neighborhood used to have
its own name and its own like weird
weirdness they scraped it all off and
now it's just like numbered cells it's
like you're on the D Block 657.
they're like dude we used to have like
the biggest part of the year was this
anything but clothes party and they
decided that that's too risky and it's
not fair to everybody and they're like I
always wonder Sean like who are the pro
like what did my prosecutors and like
judges and like regulators and people
like Elizabeth Warren what did they do
in college this is what they did in
college they shut down the party and
they're like no this is offensive we
gotta shut this party down right you
know it's like who are these people and
why do we ever let any of them have any
power and it's it's frustrating to me
that like you know schools like Sanford
and many others have had to like go
through this like identity crisis of
like I'm scared to say what I want
because you know uh what if somebody's
gonna be offended and it becomes this
meta game where like we were talking
about like yeah could I like do the
party line and say I'm really sorry my
actions have caused you know uh some
misunderstanding and blah blah blah and
have this non-apology apology but then
in like Japan the way you say no can be
found to be insulting so you just move
the meta but like the next you know
level where it's like oh you saw the way
he said no he didn't really mean it you
know the way he said I'm sorry he wasn't
really apologetic there's a real way to
say I'm sorry you got to Bow a little
bit deeper and it's like okay well so
it's it's an insane meta where you're
constantly just like getting to the next
point of of like inhibiting your
personality and what are you really
saying and just come out and say it you
know and I think that that's a really
freeing you know thing to do
yeah I don't know if it's on sub stack
but I'm on your newsletter and like you
made some wild predictions I don't
remember all the predictions but like
you may you you actually had a really
good post where you said like this is
gonna happen I think in 2023 this will
happen in 2030 I think in 50 years this
will happen and uh I I it would be
actually be fun to look back at some of
your predictions so far are turning out
to be true but it's very interesting and
you're you're pretty good at writing
actually you're quite good actually
thanks a lot you know it's it's hard to
write
um you know uh for professionally like
you guys I know Sam
um well I know Sean does for sure
if you when you're an entrepreneur doing
anything other than working on your
business seems like a waste of time and
like a a really uh painful thing to do
uh because you have to provide for your
investors or co-workers your own family
the business you love you know it's it's
uh it's hard to to do a lot of writing
in prison it was a lot easier you know
it was uh you know I had more time to
think but even then I was I was actually
really busy people will ask me if I was
you know uh you know bored in prison and
like it was the furthest thing from it a
lot of people ask me why didn't you get
jacked up you know in in prison I just
didn't have the time you know uh I was I
was working the whole time so you know
it's it's always hard to write I love
writing but but to to do anything a lot
of people ask me if I don't why don't I
do a podcast and it's the same reason
and you know the predictions about AI
are are you know some of them Echo kind
of like other people's predictions you
know in a lot of ways we have large
language models now they're really
interesting uh they certainly provide
for more eye-opening potential
predictions you know probably some of
the craziest ones I've I've made
including include things like they'll be
kind of inner species marriage between
Ai and humans they'll be AI fundamental
rights for for voting and things like
that that'll kind of reshape Society so
they're pretty wild predictions but I do
think they'll happen years from now and
I do think we're starting to see some of
those things pull in and get accelerated
uh one of my favorite people John
claremack recently upgraded his
estimate of AGI so-called artificial
general intelligence from 50 by 2030 to
60 percent you know John is like this
very precise you know calculating nerd
who's you know you know created the
first person shooter he you know His
Brilliant guy and he's working on his
own company which nobody's talking about
uh called Keen Technologies uh and I
think he's the only employee if I'm not
mistaken so he's just sitting there live
trying to create like this this brain uh
and you know who knows I think he's a
good Dark Horse for this race but no AGI
is like how is super captivating to
everyone right like it's it's to me
if you look at the history of humanity
next to maybe relativity or you know a
couple of other like magnetism
electricity like this is like probably
more important and it's the first time
humans will have created a mind from
from nothing that's stronger than human
and it's really like just so profound
that you know I don't think anybody can
afford to to ignore it it's more
profound than the internet you know it's
it's really you know something wild now
we don't know when we'll get it we'll
get a partial version of it or we're
already seeing a partial version of it
you know it's it's sort of early days
but while I was in prison I was able to
think sort of zoom out and think about
that a little bit more than maybe the
average person and it's funny if you
look at sort of open Ai and some of the
other startups that are coming out uh
these these sort of companies like
Google and Facebook you see that they
kind of did that zooming out many years
ago and the companies that are sort of
missing this and messing it up are kind
of like too close to the
to sort of reality and and the
day-to-day product management to even
see it and really understand it that
people wanted this you know Microsoft
both both Facebook and Google had a sort
of equivalent technology to open AI in
my opinion years ago and they just still
just haven't sort of seen the actual
product you know making sense and
launching and um anyway you know it's a
really interesting time obviously
what's your uh what's the new thing
so I'm releasing in the next uh a day or
two maybe even today an AI position this
will go live tomorrow this will go live
tomorrow so it might be up so what what
is there a URL so you're you're breaking
the news uh and it's so funny in
happenstance because we're talking to
like TechCrunch and like all these
places we never we didn't really find
like the perfect reporter who could
report on this so here we go uh it's
called drgupta dot AI uh it's a the
first of its kind AI physician
um it's basically going to be uh what I
hope something that could drastically
reduce health care costs interactive
drastically improve Healthcare quality
uh by providing an AI uh physician mimic
basically sort of a synthetic AI doctor
that that will can give you medical
information and I think that you know
most is your doctor or what Doctor Gupta
like
he happens to be Indian but it's also
GPT so Gupta um so anyway Dr Gupta will
give you medical information and uh you
can talk to him it's free
um it's uh to me what a lot of people
didn't understand about my price
increase and stuff like that one of the
other reasons I was out there like 50 of
them is that ninety percent of health
care costs come from Physicians
10 Comfort Pharma something what does
that mean
we spend four trillion dollars on
Healthcare in this country most of that
money goes to Physicians and healthcare
workers and
a lot of that I love doctors I love
nurses I don't have anything against
them a lot of those decisions can be
done by machines a lot of those
decisions thanks to open Ai and and deep
learning and LL models can be done by AI
so can we take that 4 trillion and make
it 2 trillion that would be a big deal
you know the whenever Cuban's doing is
not going to save anybody any money and
it's not gonna make Mark any money
either but this it could actually change
the curve on health care give us a 30
seconds on give us a 30 seconds on why
Cubans thing you you've referenced a
couple times it might be dumb or or not
that it's such a [__] show like so so
he's basically running a pharmacy right
so he's trying to Source drugs for
cheaper then mind you every other
Pharmacy is pretty good at sourcing
medicine and I don't know how he's going
to get a deal on you know say Teva or
her sons generics any better than than
CVS or Walgreens that seemed kind of
hard to do that right he's they he
doesn't have the volume they have get
that deal and then somehow get a margin
Pharmacy margins is a razor razor
freaking said right you cannot take a
three dollar drug and charge 100 bucks
for a pharmacy their razor just look
it's 10q for Walgreens and say yes like
well I'm making a fortune here and so
he's gonna somehow get a margin out of
that there's just it's just Hocus Pocus
there's no actual way to do that you
know it's it's a bunch of likes
basically he's being dishonest
so I'm on Dr oopa Dr gupa AI uh so I see
the thing so it I I tell it my age how
tall I am my weight some of my vitals if
I have lab results I entered in and then
what's gonna happen next it's gonna say
like you should check out you should
work on this this and this no you don't
actually even have to enter any of your
vitals you could just have a
conversation and we've programmed it
using these like very you know intricate
techniques I was actually
you know a lot of people are talking
about Auto GPT and and baby GPT and I
talked to Yohe and I talk to all the
people in Mena that's up
you never know what people are doing
privately but we started doing the auto
reflective GPT stuff six months ago and
we were able to discover that depending
on the technique you use you can get
better chat results than chat GPT and I
don't think openai disputes this we've
screened thousands of messages that
we've tried with the system and we get
better better performance than chat gbt
by making it kind of like Auto reflect
and do other kind of methods that again
are secret sauce that get the chat bot
to succeed so it's not so much about
that medical view it's you can get
Physician Quality advice
for free at any time any hour so you and
I may be able to call a doctor friend
but most people cannot just decide at
midnight that if they have a medical
question that they can get an answer you
have to go on Google you got to go ask
WebMD and you don't know what you're
reading half the time if you're the
average Joe you know you're not trained
in medicine if you say well what about
my chest pain what should I do you want
to talk to somebody you want to actually
have a conversation LMS do that
amazingly this isn't is a is an
attraction of gpt4 they'll actually let
you have a natural dialogue with
something that as you guys know gpt4
scores 90 percent on the USMLE it's a 90
performing most doctors don't score 90
on the boards GPT is a ace doctor uh
when it comes to medical knowledge so
being able to ask an ace doctor at any
time for free about medical information
medical advice you know it's pretty
profound product I think because again
we spend trillions of dollars on
Physicians a lot of the Physicians were
to be done by Ai and it's an
uncomfortable truth that you know again
it doesn't mean that we don't need
doctors ever again in my world in my
vision 50 years from now there's no such
thing as a medical doctor there's no
such thing as a physician that's like
I'm on the site I can I can get 50
messages for free or I pay 20 bucks a
month what's the end game here do you
think this is going to be a massive
company or is this like uh a thing where
you're like I don't know what's gonna
happen let's let's figure it out or are
you trying to get after it what are you
trying to do in the next five or ten
years with this business yeah I'm trying
to make it a massive company
um I think that you know
it you know it will be a massive company
you never say never in business but you
know we're certainly gonna try our
hardest because I do think that you can
all this is why technology has never
really been the curve for healthcare the
cost of sending a megabyte the cost of
sending uh you know storing data the
call to compute all that has dropped by
not just like 90 it dropped by like 99
and in six more nines percent Healthcare
has not moved a bit why it's because of
this Lobby that exists the AMA restricts
the amount of people who could become
doctors the supply is constrained you
cannot just graduate a million more
doctors tomorrow if we could do that
what would happen the price of Medical
Services would drop like a rock we our
country would be saved Medicare and
Medicaid wouldn't be going bankrupt we
have a huge wouldn't be bankrupting us
if we had a million more doctors
tomorrow Healthcare wouldn't be a
problem in America the problem is we
don't have a million more doctors in
America one of the reasons is there's
not going to be a million people who
pass med school the other problem is the
AMA specifically says there's only this
many Medicals there's only this many uh
doctors graduating from med school we're
gonna make it really hard to become a
doctor even though AI can do all these
things very easily and you're going to
see a lot of Industries collapse because
of GPT I think whether it's law medicine
accounting there's going to be a huge
change in society thanks to Ai and GPT
so how is this not like self-driving
cars where even though self-driving is
almost like better than a human in in a
bunch of different circumstances maybe
not certain weather conditions uh but if
it gets one thing wrong it's you know
all the news and all the lawsuits and so
they need to be not just better they
need to be so much better that they can
kind of overcome that like how do you
not just get sued out of existence for
the you know the the you know one
mistaken medical diagnosis or or
um you know treatment plan or whatever
it is here how do you how do you avoid
that problem
sure I think it's a lot like like
self-driving cars where if you gave me
the story where there's 50 000 all the
fatalities a year right in America and I
can press this button right here and
there's gonna be twenty thousand there's
two types of people in the world there's
the first type of person who says that's
amazing 30 000 lives saved 30 000 less
funerals thirty thousand less torn
families destroyed by needless you know
terrible you know uh automobile fatality
what a horrible you know thing I'm so
happy I can't wait to push that button
you know anything stop me from pushing
that button is is insane right so why
would you delay that for half a second
and then you've got the kind of person
similar to the Stanford party who says
well wait a second are there going to be
20 000 deaths from from this that's an
outrage I can't believe it don't push
that button and obviously one side is
riding one side's wrong you know but the
the the technical progress of the world
cannot be stopped I'm part of this IAC
group effective accelerationism which is
this like new movement that's counter
effective altruism so you see the E
forward slash ACC we've got a lot of
really exciting members some of the
biggest people in technology uh and it's
this sort of like underground movement
of people who don't want to slow down AI
but people who don't want to slow down
uh technology and I think that
um you know the idea that we're here to
stop progress because the technology
might make one mistake and remember
that's sort of like stopping the
automobile because the automobile itself
was an improvement over the horse we
have to move forward in the world we
can't look back and nitpick on every
single mistake in life and I think
that's that's sort of I know that's not
how you feel Sean but that kind of
criticism and that kind of like attitude
is such a terrible pernicious threat to
our well-being that like we have to look
at the class not just have full because
it's 90 full we can't look at the 10
that's empty right yeah I mean I get it
philosophically it's like the trolley
problem it's like 10 people the Train's
gonna run over 10 people if I pull this
lever it'll run over those other two and
uh you know there's a whatever people
have people feel different ways about
that I guess what I mean is like
practically speaking that for this
company like how does this company not
die because something like that's gonna
happen what are you going to do like
what do you think
our purpose and policies make sure that
you understand that this is medical
advice Dr coop is not a real doctor that
if you uh use our website for medical
information it's simply for
informational purposes only and you have
to I mean I can reach the whole
disclaimer but the reality of the matter
is that do you want somebody who's 75
years old okay who has uh pneumonia but
doesn't know that they have pneumonia uh
they have a cough but they're gonna die
in pneumonia if they don't go to
hospital next three days do you want
that person running around Google trying
to figure out if they have pneumonia or
not or do you want them to to go to an
llm what's better if you don't have the
llm they're going to go to Google
they're going to go to WebMD they're
going to try to read it on their own
they're going to mess it up
there's a decent chance whereas if you
go to llm you might actually get the
superior technology that may save their
life so you're net improving it and if
you don't want a net Improvement then
you're Elizabeth Warren you're a lotite
you're et cetera Etc and if you want the
Improvement you're on the side right
side of history and I think that if you
look at the way technology informs
regulation not the other way around
right regulation has to serve the people
if the people are getting the benefit
the people will demand the right side if
you have people that want to stand in a
way of of improvement that's up to them
listen if if we're told you got a block
Dr Gupta in this state or this country
okay the Philippines will have it
remember TPT is is is
um knows every single language it's
lingual in every single language in the
world so Japan will have this for free
tomorrow it's like Pitbull Mr worldwide
right it's a global product and that's
the amazing thing about being a
developer you normally have to worry
about localization right language all
that crap it's gone now it's CPT this Dr
Gupta knows every language they beta
tested this in Spanish
we might localize him and make him like
doctor somebody else in in Latin America
but Dr Gupta matches GPT our other
option was Dr Lim llm so oh we picked Dr
Dr Gupta because he's literally Dr GPT
honestly it's kind of a genius name as
an Indian person I I will give it my
seal of approval uh I think that's is
very clear thank you very clever
um
about six months ago or nine months ago
I was talking to you and you had a
crypto company that was like a 3D
modeling company for drugs what happened
to that company did you ditch it or is
it you do both or what so it's all it's
all under one Hood so our company is
called DL software uh we've raised some
some money from from some really
well-known people in in the valley it's
been you know again an interesting
dilemma where you have like
people who want to support you like all
these people actually said that my
YouTube Finance videos you mentioned
content creating that it got them
through like a stain Adventure Time I
watched a ton of those I watched all
those thank you and and like I'm so
lucky that these people some of whom
started some of the biggest software
companies in our industry uh literally
like maybe the top five unicorns and
software like three of the Four Seasons
like that where where like I messaged
these guys they're like oh you're my
teacher I'm like so flattered you know
that these billionaires are are like on
myself that really happened and they're
like yeah
sorry that really happened
yeah a billionaire several millionaires
you know several billionaires are
lusters in our several billionaires have
smashed the Subscribe button hit the
turn notifications on leave leave a
message in the comments on YouTube I
love it it's really really humbling
because it's like you know
you know you couldn't find that kind of
content where like you could you could
talk to somebody who was a publicly
traded company CEO showing you like step
by step kind of what their job was like
and I think more than just like how to
read a balance sheet I taught an
attitude too that kind of the one thing
I learned from grammar which is like
this hardcore attitude of like you love
this stuff you're up like people would
watch me stream like four in the morning
like getting ready to go you know tear
the world and a new [__] because I'm
so like excited about doing my job and I
think it got a lot of people out of a
funk or out of like a hard time and like
just pushing people like push harder
push harder that worked for so many
people at these at these unicorns these
Mega unicorns these like 10x unicorns
that that yeah that's why I said you're
amazing at content because you have the
trifecta there's three things it takes
to be great at content
the first is unique perspective or you
need unique POV right so you you have
unique unique specific set of knowledge
that the average person doesn't have
okay that's most people would expect
that now here's the unexpected ones you
do energy transmission so uh most
content is actually just a transfer of
my energy and excitement or outrage
about whatever it is to you and if I'm
able to express it if I can show you
that I'm Juiced up about this I've
watched you at your computer that you
like get up you do push-ups on the
ground you're like pumped up about
whatever or you're calling somebody out
or whatever it is it's energy
transmission and the last thing you're
like a reality TV person you kind of
know what you're supposed to say but you
don't really care and you want to say
what you like you don't really care you
care more about like uh saying the thing
than what people will think of you
saying the thing and uh some for some
reality TV people it's because they're
just not aware they don't know it you
know it and you just don't care you like
override that sensor and you're like no
that sensor doesn't get to decide what's
going on here and so you have you have
all three and I think that that's what
makes your streams so impressive like
you said at the beginning of this I
don't do the like just wing it but I
I've seen you just wait and I actually
think that's your best content so I
don't know what you meant by that
we're just like closing the loop on it
like I only started those streams
because you know I didn't want people to
think I was the farmer bro which I was
like being characterized as and I
basically wanted people to like judge
for themselves like see a day in my life
see if like you think I'm a dick or not
and some people said yeah I still think
you're a dick but I've seen people said
you know I kind of like this guy and you
know maybe this is like a little bit of
what I want to be like um and so the
point is like I'm so lucky that the
people who watched that in 2015 2016
obviously not all of them became [__]
but a handful of them the top couple
people became unbelievably successful
and that's maybe because of me maybe not
because of me maybe it's in spite of me
you know but the the whole point that
they some of them thank me for it is as
I'm really lucky for that I have three
software products under or sort of
umbrella here but I think that like the
key thing for our company is is getting
amazing talent you know in in any
industry but especially in Tech like the
only really thing that matters is this
combination of capital and people and
you know the capital is easy to get you
know there's there's in infinite capital
in the world it's it's about you know do
you have the people to execute the plan
and and I'm so lucky that like a little
bit of this personal profile gets great
Engineers to come to the table and talk
doesn't always get them in the door but
the fact that like we can do that and
like the one skill I have as a manager
to your to your to your point is that
energy transfer like getting people like
can you can I pump you up about making a
synthetic doctor well to some people
that might be really boring and if you
pitch it the wrong way if you're like at
a big Healthcare Company you're like
well we're going to make medical
information you know uh diagnostic tools
Etc et cetera it sounds like [__] you
know but if you if you do it the right
way and you explain to the engineer that
there's if we do our jobs right there's
no such thing as a doctor in 30 years
that every operation every prescription
every piece of medical advice you ever
get from now on comes from a machine and
it costs 10 cents that changes the world
that's something that you're gonna leave
a legacy we're gonna make a fortune
we're gonna have a lot of fun and it's
Gonna Change the World for everyone for
the Indonesian that can't see a doctor
for 30 days and the doctor they're
seeing is a very questionable variety
you know in in Providence to be able to
get the best medical expertise of an
American physician that's insane right
and we're getting that tomorrow and I
think that again you can't get a
prescription from Dr Gupta and he's not
going to cut out your bunion but I think
that the fact that we can even talk
Touch by 10 of health care costs that's
hundreds of billions of dollars it's
bigger than Google's Tampa it's a whole
like you know Healthcare is one of these
just gigantic spots that has never been
chunked by by technology despite the
best attempts of Sand Hill Road like
billions of dollars flew into digital
hell there's just no obvious way to take
a sledgehammer of this you have to
understand that Healthcare is is
basically all money that goes to people
who just slosh it around for this like
very AI simple simple problem for AI for
that little advice of yeah you should
take this beta Walker should not take
this Beta Blocker we should do the
surgery or not do the surgery and that
human advice is really important but at
the same time like you know a good chunk
think of it could probably be automated
the last thing I wanted to bring up was
like so I I ran this company called The
Hustle which we wrote about you and you
actually were homies with uh Brina this
woman who worked for me and you were
like at one point we were like hey come
visit me in San Diego and I remember
like yeah and Trung yeah and I remember
like right when your story broke it was
Pharma bro and then I got to like I you
and I chatted on blab before and I I
don't know if you remember we've taught
before I'm like it's funny this guy's
not really a bro at all like he's he's
just a nerd he's just like care he like
you know he talks a lot like and he's
confident but he's like like a pretty
nerdy guy and the reason
it's so funny about media perception the
reason your story did I think the way it
all like started was do you have this
picture I'm looking at it now it's you
wearing like Ray-Bans and a red Polo and
you have like a picture of what looks
like Flowrider in the back like on a
music video in a Bugatti and you're like
pointing down like this and you're like
your jawline looks cut and you look like
the broyiest of Bros and I remember when
we wrote this story in the hustle we
tried a bunch of different photos and
that photo did best because it's just
like you're just like giving into this
big old stereotype and uh
[__] picture ruined you man so the
backstory is funny like we had just done
this stock trade it was in my personal
account we made 20 million dollars
shorting uh the stock called vital
therapies they were developing a liver
dialysis machine we spent day and night
stalking this company and figuring out
everything about the attempt to make a
liver dialysis machine works for a
kidney really well they wanted to take
that same idea and apply to the liver
sounds good right doesn't work there are
a lot of technical reasons me and two
colleagues spent day in day out stalking
figuring this coming out we wrote a
40-page report we put the report out the
stock fell like 40 just on the report
two weeks later the drug the device
ended up proving that it didn't work it
didn't help anybody with severe liver
disease then the stock went down like 90
and we were short the stock and so the
day went down we did that uh the Florida
song is called it's going down or
something like that and so I was like
you know doing this like thing because
like we thought these guys were
basically fraudsters you know lying
about
their liver device which had proven that
it doesn't even help people it probably
hurts them but they were still trying to
get through that like Venture Capital
grind and and uh public grind of like
lying and trying to make [__] stick and
and make put the best you know spin on
things and so when we shorted it and it
went down it was going down you know
that was the kind of joke and I was like
oh how funny would it be if I you know
dressed up like a bro for a second and
like we had a friend in the trade too we
had a couple friends in the trade like
putting it on Twitter was was kind of
like a oh check it out like it's going
down because of us because we wrote the
short report and again what the next
like two weeks the same I made it like
my profile pic in like the next two
weeks like that that's what everyone
seized on it's like oh yeah
yeah like this picture is like it's just
so funny like I don't know the whole
fact of your story and you admitted
wrongdoing and everything but it's like
it was it was Amplified and uh this
picture was like the beginning of the
end for you this one picture that's what
it seems because I remember this one
picture going
the beginning of an interesting story
I I to me like now I'll take it and try
like you would look at it and many other
people's look at us beginning the end I
look at it as Life's a just a crazy ride
it's a crazy movie you know it would be
very boring to like be a value investor
for the next 50 years and make 100
billion dollars doing gram and Dodd
stock picking like so it's right for
somebody else thought right for my life
and it is the path I chose you know not
like you know it was an intentional
choice you know maybe not the wisest
choice but it is the choice for me and
you know I I don't regret having had
like a really interesting exciting life
there are moments of it that weren't fun
but there's it's still one of these
things where I'm not like deeply ashamed
of like something I did or something
like that like it's a conscious choice I
made to sort of like do the things I did
the photo was you know it was alarming
to me that the media could take like an
image and say okay this is this person
what's what's cast it this way and I
think it sort of backfired in the long
run you know I I'm sort of popular than
ever and you know kind of doing just
fine so so if you there's a price to be
paid if you could go yeah if you could
go back would you have advised you know
if you can go back and kind of whisper
in the ear of yourself at any point in
time you know would you have told
yourself hey if you're going on TV don't
don't don't say that thing don't don't
be smugged don't do this don't do that
would you have played it differently
knowing what you know now
I think I I think like you know there's
two sides of the story with like the
rationalist would say of course you know
like tone it down here you know tuck in
your you know tug that in there tuck in
your shirt there you know straighten up
there uh metaphorically but the the I
think the oldest wisdom is know thyself
right and it's like just be yourself
know yourself be who you are and like if
you spend the rest of your life trying
to make somebody else happy and and
conforming to society it's gonna be not
a life worth living and if you spend
your life answering to your own
conscience I think then you know you you
can no matter what happens No Matter
Stick put you in jail for lesser life
you'll you'll have the at least have
something nobody could take away from
you which is like your your own identity
and your own personality and I think
there's a lot like William Wallace like
William Wallace and Braveheart you know
they'll take our freedom or whether they
say they'll take our lives we'll never
take our freedom
you know there's there's there's a point
in time where you have to be a real
person and I think like if you want to
be a corporate sort of like mimic of
like every other corporate person in the
world you know that's a that's a life
issue that's life you want that that's
life you want there's just only so much
of the life that that I can take and for
me I had it when it came to like the
media like you said you know with with
the Flo Rida picture or or whatever the
typecasting it was like you know I I
can't that's that's a line that was too
much for me so I think it's it's
probably more reactive than anything
else like Hillary Clinton tweeting at me
and stuff like that it was like so
surreal like me you know the mild man or
pharmaceutical executive yeah I'm I'm
the object of your [__] scorn you
know this is nuts you know so a lot of
it was that like provoke and and be
provided like it you know it it was not
like easy to to sit there and just do
nothing so like it's easy like yeah I'll
turn it on you guys like it's very easy
to sort of throw advice out but when
you're in a hot seat and somebody says
oh aren't you this and aren't you that
and you know you say well you know I'm
sorry I caused some disturbance here and
I'm just really you know uh it's really
hard to do that you know sometimes you
um
first of all that's hilarious second of
all uh you don't know a super well but
before our old kind of podcast setup Sam
used to have these photos on the wall of
like his hollow there's like personal
Hall of Fame and it'd be like you know
some Inspirations from business like Sam
before he started the hustle he really
loved Ted Turner he's like dude this guy
like made the [__] news business and
he's a baller like he he attacked it in
this way he had Nate Diaz up there he's
like I love this guy he's a UFC fighter
he's like just a badass that just takes
this attitude into into life that's that
we like you know I like Conor McGregor
and I think you know he's interesting
and I like you know certain things that
he's done about his life you know I
don't like all of these people I just
like certain things I took inspiration
from certain things at certain periods
of certain people's lives who were kind
of who are some people that you were
inspired by either in the business world
or the non-business world uh that that
you think are you sort of have admired
or you've gone down the YouTube rabbit
hole and just you know uh binged a bunch
of their content or whatever
I'll start with Vince McMahon
um you know so when I when I started to
be this like bad guy and I realized that
there was nothing I could do to change
that narratives like I could do a two
hour interview with ABC you're the
Healer and they would take the 30
seconds that [__] me and and make the
30 seconds Loop and like forget the
other you know 119 minutes those 30
seconds or the ones that are gonna be on
TV I realize like there's no way out of
this and I'm gonna have to embrace being
the bad guy and some people will get the
joke and and some people won't uh but
you know [__] it if if if that's what
people want then I'll be the bad guy and
I sort of embrace Ida being this jerk
and trying to dress down you know the
so-called Authority uh figures
um by by sort of pointing you know
pointing the the mirror back at them
um so Vince Vince sort of like had that
like kafabe wrestling you know they call
it a heel in wrestling uh where you know
he's he's the owner of the company but
he's also kind of like breaking down
that fourth wall of like some of the
stuff he's talking about on the show oh
is like related to actual boardroom
battles and like some of the you know
stuff on the show is is completely
contrived and you know it's just a
fantastic product and I like the company
and what they've done with it over the
years so you know I'm a big fan of
Vince's
um
you know I I like a lot of like
different scientists and stuff like that
um you know so business people
themselves you know there aren't a whole
lot that I like point to and say oh
that's somebody I'd like to be like or
something like that but growing up I
always like Bill Gates who was kind of
this you know smug hated by the way in
94 Bill Gates was was sued for Monopoly
but his company was not him and people
wanted to tear this guy apart and I was
just sort of coming up I was like 11
years old I love computers I started
programming and I was like everyone
hates Bill Gates in the hacker Community
hated Bill Gates and and it's because he
wanted to make money and he's not
apologetic about it and I kind of like
this guy I liked the contrarianism of
being like you know what I like
Microsoft I like building no one's
willing to say that and like we wouldn't
have these things that we're all using
Microsoft products right now like what
would we be doing without it and you
know the Linux nerds would be like well
you know we can we don't have to use
them and it's like look The Whole
World's using them for a reason they're
pretty good products and I I just sort
of liked taking that bad guy and at the
time he was really hated and sort of
saying you know I'm on his side you know
the media was on his case because he was
the richest guy in the world but
couldn't afford a good haircut you know
they always just dog him for no reason
and he spent the rest of his life like
trying to walk back on that and like how
cool it had been if he sort of embraced
The Narrative like yeah you know because
privately he doesn't race The Narrative
right it's just a it's just sort of this
public image of like no no I'm I'm this
benevolent philanthropist you don't
understand you know privately the guy's
still just as ruthless still just as
vicious and just as energetic and
intense as he was when he was a kid so
you know it's it's all this like you
know imagery for for nothing
um and you know there's a number of
other folks like uh Henry Nicholas who
started broadcom you know I I mean I
there's just so many people that you
know I've studied in business over the
years that I like Tom petters from
interactive brokers
um so many people I admire that that did
things their way
um and and made it work uh people
especially who who sort of have come
from nothing came from like with very
little on their back a lot of people dog
George Soros uh you know who's you know
uh a true American success story and
people sort of forget that you know or
don't understand that like all the stuff
in politics and like service funded
prosecutor and stuff like that that
barely pays attention to [__] you know I
think that like the idea that he's
spending his day like plotting with you
know the uh you know the world economic
forums like around the world is this
like right-wing meme that's just not not
based in reality and you know the guys
work in hedge funds and investing is is
like truly remarkable how he came from
like sort of the you know World War II
basically to to America to become truly
successful so people like that I admire
you know anyone who's sort of had this
Against All Odds type of success
um you know even people like uh Robert
Smith you know who run Vista
um you know people who have like really
bucked you know any conventions and
expectations of them to to be really
successful so there's so many people
that I have up there on that wall uh and
again it's not you know every like you
said it's not every piece of their life
but little pieces of sort of made me I
have Bill Gates on mine because of the
the interview where about the chair
jumping over there
I still think that's the most gangster
like CEO interview moment I don't even
know how this came up and then he he's
she I think the interview was like
you know how to jump over a chair he
goes yeah no no he goes do it he goes I
think it depends on the height of the
chair and then it cuts to a chair and
clearing it like Tony Hawk and I have no
explanation why this was like is this
what TV interviews were like back then
like I can't imagine something like
that's like being like Donald Trump like
is it true you could win an arm
wrestling match against anyone he's like
well rolls up his sleeve it just like
punks dude I'm watching this video by
the way amazing
it's not that impressive it's not a big
chair you don't think you could jump
over it never would have done something
nerdy shrimpy guy he's actually 511. uh
but like there's this jump over that
chair
yeah dude he takes a step I bet you
could jump over the chair bro you need a
chair I'll give you a chance I want to
recreate this scene I'll we'll put it on
our YouTube I don't think I could jump
over this chair and I was like I I play
basketball I think I I was I would in my
head I'm more athletic than Bill Gates
but honestly I can't claim that until I
do this chair oh no man he's probably
only 35 in this video I think you could
jump to it I turn 35 next week it's
perfect uh me versus Bill Gates
head-to-head pay-per-view we gotta do it
uh Martin thanks for doing this man um
we appreciate it we um I know that like
I don't I won't out you but I know that
you've got like some Anonymous accounts
online normally where can people find
you but for you you get banned every
like third week so it's not that useful
and we were like is are we even talking
to the real Martin it's even gonna come
like what is he we weren't even sure if
we were talking to the right guy the um
interesting thing about that is I think
the world's changing quite a bit like
like the sensitivity of banning people
on Twitter has now given away so I'm
actually starting to talk to Twitter I
still need my old Twitter account is at
Morton shkreli it's in the process
hopefully being on band but any anybody
that can help me get that on band I'd
really appreciate it
um uh right now I'm at Marty underscore
catboy which an ex-girlfriend made for
me which you know uh has stock for some
reason not my Carlos Twitter handle you
know on Instagram on Mario's probably
15.
um yeah I I love social media but you
know getting banned from I'm banned from
Tinder and hinge and you know like so
many odd you know social medias uh on
YouTube but you're banned from Tinder
why I don't know I think like part of it
is this um that's like the definition of
a [__] block right like they just banned
you from dating what's going on I I
think this cancel cancel culture like
extends into virtually anything right
and uh for Tinder it's it's uh you know
you can argue that like well how do we
know it's the real person right that
that sort of one argument but even then
like I just think there's somebody at
the match herb that just doesn't like me
um but you know it is what it is uh I'll
live but yeah Twitter is uh is like this
my lifelong goal is to get unbanned from
Twitter because it's been seven years
and I actually went to jail for a
shorter period of time than I've been in
Twitter jail so like you know I I was
banned I went to prison came out and I'm
still banned for what did you get banned
just like you like asked somebody to get
you a lock of Hillary Clinton's hair
wasn't that the reason why it wasn't
that it was it was I was teasing this
woman who who I was it was like this
very left-wing journalist and I was kind
of like ripping her a little bit over
politics and stuff like that and
apparently I went too far but like it
was obviously you know selective bias I
mean it was like insanely selective for
a lifetime beta you know it was a joke
uh I made about her husband or something
and it was just like too far and it's
like look words are in that and
dangerous you know yeah nobody's getting
hurt by these words you know and they're
going back and forth It's a two-way
street you know out but it you know what
I did was way too over the line and what
she did was totally fine you know it was
just this like insane uh perspective so
I'm hoping Elon or somebody can get me
unbanned because it's been seven years
uh and I was skyrocketing with followers
and Views and that's the thing about
cancel culture right you have somebody
who's taking off their narrative is is
boosting they're improving I was
improving my reputation daraprim was
starting to look like the rear-reviewed
mirror of me I was moving on the
controversy was over a revenue was doing
fine and then you know Twitter said no
can't let you keep going right and it's
like if you try to stop people from like
taking back their narrative and you you
can halt them like that it's a very
dangerous thing for Tech to be able to
censor people like that like imagine
having somebody become really
controversial and say no I want to tell
my side of the story and somebody says
no you don't get that chance you know
it's kind of a disgusting thing
well dude we appreciate this man that
you're a fascinating person and we hope
that uh I imagine we'll be talking more
um I'm very curious to see how Dr Dr
Gupta is going to do
um but thank you for for coming and
doing this we were like I said we were
like I'm not sure if he's coming or not
we're not we're 50 50 chance so I'm
happy we made this happen and we
appreciate you thank you so much guys
all right we'll talk soon awesome that's
it that's the pod
[Music]
foreign